-Performing his hit "Golden Hour"
from his debut album, "This is What Blank Feels Like,"
with the a little help from the New York Youth Symphony,
please welcome JVKE. [jake]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ It was just two lovers ♪
♪ Sittin' in the car, listening to Blonde ♪
♪ Fallin' for each other ♪
♪ Pink and orange skies, feelin' super childish ♪
♪ No Donald Glover ♪
♪ Missed call from my mother ♪
♪ Like, "Where you at tonight?" ♪
♪ Got no alibi ♪
♪ I was all alone with the love of my life ♪
♪ She's got glitter for skin ♪
♪ My radiant beam in the night ♪
♪ I don't need no light to see you ♪
♪ Shine ♪
♪ It's your golden hour ♪
♪ Ohh ♪
♪ You slow down time ♪
♪ In your golden hour ♪
♪ Ohh ♪
♪♪
Yeah, that's it. Yeah.
♪ We were just two lovers ♪
♪ Feet up on the dash, drivin' nowhere fast ♪
♪ Burnin' through the summer ♪
♪ Radio on blast, make the moment last ♪
♪ She got solar power ♪
♪ Minutes feel like hours ♪
♪ She knew she was the baddest, can you even imagine ♪
♪ Fallin' like I did? ♪
♪ For the love of my life ♪
♪ She's got glow on her face ♪
♪ A glorious look in her eyes ♪
♪ My angel of light ♪
♪ I was all alone with the love of my life ♪
♪ She's got glitter for skin ♪
♪ My radiant beam in the night ♪
♪ Oh, I don't need no light to see you ♪
♪ Shine ♪
It's your golden hour
♪ Ohh ♪
♪ You slow down time ♪
♪ In your golden hour ♪
♪ Ohh-ohh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]